[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Great.
Now let's dive into
the material today.
So today's topic is
carbohydrates as well as
an introduction to
membrane structure.
And from the very
first class, I believe
Professor Yaffe talked to you
about the four main classes
of biological molecules.
So proteins and
amino acids, you've
spent a lot of time
talking about that.
Nucleic acids is coming up.
And the other two
are carbohydrates
or sugars and lipids.
Today, we're really going
to focus most of the lecture
on carbohydrates, what
they are, structure,
something about nomenclature.
And then at the end, we're
going to talk a little bit
about lipids and basic
membrane structure.
Now carbohydrates and lipids are
really critical energy storage
molecules for cells.
And when we talk
about metabolism--
the most interesting
part of this course--
after spring break,
we're going to delve
into this in a lot more detail.
But sugars are also very
important to understand
nucleic acid structure.
Turns out, membranes
are essential for signal
transduction.
Those are the two major
topics that Professor Yaffe
is going to talk about
for the rest of his time.
And so this year, we're going
to try something different
and have me introduce at
least some of these topics
now, which will deal with some
redundancies that otherwise
might have existed
and maybe set it up
better for him to discuss some
of the lectures coming up.
Now today's lecture is
unfortunately topically
a little bit disjointed.
But it still has important
information about biochemistry.
And it will help us all
speak the same language,
both for the upcoming lectures
from Professor Yaffe as well
as things that I will start
off with when I come back.
And it's a nice way to ease
back in after the exam.
OK.
So what is a
carbohydrate or a sugar?
So let's break this down,
and so it's carbohydrate.
So a carbohydrate is
effectively carbon
in some ratio with water.
So all carbohydrates have
the same chemical formula, Cn
and H2On.
And so there are some
deviations from this in biology.
Sometimes, you can introduce a
heteroatom, phosphate, sulfur,
nitrogen, et cetera.
Technically, these
are not carbohydrates,
although they're often lumped
together with carbohydrates.
And why would nature do this?
Because it changes some
of the chemical properties
that can be useful for either
structural or signaling
reasons.
You may encounter these later--
certainly, in other classes.
But we're not going to talk
much more about that today.
We really just kind of focus
on the base carbohydrate,
Cn H2On structure.
Now carbohydrates come
in different forms.
And so they can come as single
units with that structure.
These are so-called
monosaccharides.
Or these single units
can come together
to form various polymers.
And those polymers could be two
units, so-called disaccarides--
so two sugars stuck together.
Or many units, and
so sometimes, those
are referred to as
oligosaccharides
or polysaccharides.
And there's really
no clear distinction
between a few chains
together, oligosaccharides,
many polysaccharides.
They're somewhat
used interchangeably.
Now you guys have
almost certainly
heard of many of these things.
So what's a monosaccharide?
So a good example
of that is glucose.
So glucose is, of
course, the main sugar
that exists in your blood.
What's a disaccharide?
So a common one is sucrose.
So sucrose is a disaccharide--
so two sugars stuck together,
glucose plus fructose.
You've probably heard of
both of those things before.
Sucrose is, of
course, table sugar.
It's what you would have
mixed into your coffee
if you had that this morning.
And an example of a
polysaccharide is starch--
so what's in a potato.
All right.
Now clearly, these
are all sugars.
They're all relevant
to a human diet.
You would never confuse--
you've probably not
knowingly tasted glucose.
It's not particularly sweet.
Sucrose is much sweeter.
And a potato is not
necessarily sweet at all.
Yet, this really points out
that how these sugars are built,
the different
structures matter a lot.
They matter for things like how
you taste them in your diet.
And how carbohydrates
are built also
matters a lot for all kinds
of aspects of biology, which
is why it's somewhat important
to at least understand
some of what we're talking
about-- a common language
about how to describe
these molecules.
OK.
So the simplest
biological sugars
have three carbons that
are least commonly used.
These are referred
to as trioses.
And if we take the
general formula,
C3 H2O3, and we say,
what are two ways that we
can satisfy that formula?
There's two main
ways we can do it.
One is like this.
So if you add up--
count all the carbons,
hydrogens, and oxygens,
you will see that
that is C3 H2O3.
This molecule is
called glyceraldehyde.
OK.
And the other way we can
do this is like this.
OK.
Again, three carbons,
three waters.
If you add up all the
atoms, this molecule
is called dihydroxyacetone.
And these are sugar--
same chemical formula,
different chemical structure.
That has a term.
That's called an isomer.
And it turns out that
we can chemically
interconvert these molecules
in the following way.
And so if we carry
out this chemistry,
we will get this intermediate.
OK.
And that will allow you to
interconvert glyceraldehyde--
this aldehyde-- with this
ketone, dihydroxyacetone.
And the enzyme class
that carries this out
is a class of enzymes
called isomerases.
And this is exactly
the chemistry
that that enzyme would
use to interconvert
these two forms of this
triose, this three-carbon sugar
molecule.
All right.
Now if we look at
dihydroxyacetone,
there's no stereocenter here.
What do I mean by
a stereocenter?
That's a carbon that
has-- reminder from 512--
carbon that has four different
non-equivalent substituents
around it.
However, if you look
at glyceraldehyde,
that carbon in the middle
is a stereocenter--
four non-equivalent
groups around it.
And so there's two ways that
I can draw glyceraldehyde.
I can draw it like this.
Or I could draw it like this.
All right-- so two
different ways.
So the one on the left
here is D-glyceraldehyde.
And the one on the right
is L-glyceraldehyde.
OK.
And I know that this is review.
Some people are good
at seeing these things.
Some people are not.
I brought a couple
of models here.
Here's this-- the
blue and the brown
are two stereocenters with four
different constituents on them.
No way you can twist these
around to make them identical
molecules.
Why does this matter?
Well, enzyme-active
sites are going
to fit this molecule
different than this molecule.
And this is why
these stereoisomers
matter so much for biology.
It's also something that's
really hard to accomplish.
If you think about how
do you actually generate
stereoisomers if you were in
an organic chemistry lab--
really hard.
But biology does
this all the time.
And the real reason
is because it's
enzymes that ultimately
catalyze these interconversions.
And different stereoisomers
will fit differently
into enzyme-active sites.
Now the way that I've
been drawing these sugars
is a convention called
a Fischer projection.
And when drawn in this way,
the convention is that--
so you put the carbonyl
towards the top.
If the OH group, the alcohol,
is pointing to the right,
that's D. If it's pointing
to the left, that's L--
and so D, pointing to the
right, L, pointing to the left.
Like amino acids, biology has
chosen one stereochemistry
for most biological
sugars because, of course,
enzymes act on them.
And so in biology,
it's D, sugars.
This is in contrast
to L, amino acids.
And so if you can remember
that sugars are D,
you know that amino
acids are the opposite.
Or if you remember
that amino acids are L,
you can remember that
sugars are the opposite.
OK.
All right.
So dihydroxyacetone is
really the only sugar
with three or more carbons that
doesn't have a chiral center.
Everything else will.
And so if I go to a
four-carbon sugar--
draw a couple of them here.
OK.
So here's C4 H2O4
drawn with a ketone.
If you look at this,
this is a chiral center.
OH group is pointing
to the right.
This is a D sugar.
If I had drawn it with
the OH group on this side,
it would be an L sugar.
All right.
If I draw this sugar as a
different isomer, this time
with an aldehyde, now, we
encounter a bit of an issue
because now I have
one, two stereocenters.
OK.
So if there's two
stereocenters, that
means there's 2 to
the n ways that I can
draw this as a stereoisomer.
And so you can see that this
could get really complicated
very quickly.
Now this sugar obviously is a
D because I drew both OH groups
pointing to the right.
But you can imagine, I
could draw one this way
or one that way.
And so how do if it's
a D or an L sugar?
And so the convention
is that whether or not
a sugar is designated
as D or L refers
to the stereocenter
that is furthest away
from the carbonyl.
And so this is the
relevant stereocenter
that says it's a D sugar.
So what do I mean?
I can draw.
And then any other sugar
would have a different name.
And so what do I mean by that?
Let me draw this a
few different ways.
And so the sugar
that I've drawn here
is referred to as D-erythrose.
All right.
If I draw it, now the
OH group on the carbon
furthest from the carbonyl
pointing to the left,
so this would be L-erythrose.
And if I draw it
differently by altering
the stereochemistry
of this carbon,
now, it has a different name.
And so this carbon is D--
or this sugar is D-threose.
All right.
Makes sense.
If I flip the OH group to this
side, it would be L-threose.
All right.
So lots of possibilities.
Turns out nature only uses a
subset of the stereoisomers
and makes them
relevant for biology.
For example,
D-erythrose is something
that you will encounter when
we talk about metabolism
later in the course.
D-threose, as far as I know,
is not used in biology.
I would never say, it's
never used in biology.
Never bet against biology.
It can do absolutely everything.
There's always an
exception somewhere.
But, in general,
D-threose is not
something that really exists,
at least commonly in nature.
All right.
So if we go through,
and you look
at all of these different
sugars that I've drawn,
you can see that they
either have an aldehyde,
or they have a ketone
somewhere in the molecule.
All right.
So if you have an
aldehyde, these sugars
are generically
referred to as aldoses.
All right.
And if you have a ketone,
an internal carbonyl,
these are generically
referred to as ketoses.
Now you might say,
as you start getting
to longer and longer sugars,
you can put the ketone anywhere
along the sugar, and
there would be a ton
of different possibilities.
But it turns out
ketoses always have
the carbonyl as the second
carbon in from the end.
The reason for that
is because biology,
as you will see when we
talk about metabolism,
interconverts these via
isomerase reactions.
And so you can't use
an isomerase reaction
to interconvert a
ketose and an aldose
unless the ketone is one carbon
away from the end of the sugar.
And so this fact
really limits some
of the diversity of ketoses that
can actually exist in nature.
Now most important
biological sugars,
at least the most
common ones, end up
having six carbons
or five carbons.
And these are referred
to as hexoses or aldose--
or pentoses.
Sorry-- so much nomenclature.
OK.
So six-carbon
sugars are hexoses.
Five-carbon sugars are pentoses.
And if we just talk
about the hexoses,
you're very familiar
with a couple of them.
And so one that we mentioned
earlier, blood sugar--
glucose looks like this.
So this molecule is D-glucose.
It's a D sugar because
the stereocenter here
furthest from the carbonyl--
OH group points to the right.
So it's a D sugar.
It's an aldose because
it has an aldehyde.
All right.
And it's a hexose because it
has 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 carbons.
And what makes it glucose
is the stereochemistry
of these other sites
that end up being-- this
is the molecule glucose.
Now if I carry out
that isomerase reaction
that I showed you earlier,
it'll give me this intermediate.
Let me draw the whole thing.
Then I interconvert that aldose.
Now, it becomes a ketose.
This is D-fructose--
another common sugar that
certainly is in the news a lot.
D sugar because the
stereocenter for this
from the carbonyl points to
the right, makes it a D sugar.
It's a ketose.
It's a hexose.
This organization of
other stereocenters
is what makes it D-fructose.
All right.
Now if we go through
and we count these,
there's four stereocenters in
glucose, three stereocenters
in fructose.
That means 2 to the n.
There are 16 ways I can
make ketose aldose, eight
ways I can make a ketose--
I'm sorry-- an aldose
hexose, eight ways
I can make a ketose hexose.
Among those, that's
even 12 different ways
that I can have D hexoses that
are a ketose or an aldose.
Could be very, very complicated.
But it turns out, fructose is
the only D hexose ketose that
really is relevant for nature.
There's only two other
molecules related to glucose--
only two other hexose aldoses
that are sugars used in nature.
You've probably heard
of these as well.
I'll draw them to illustrate
a different point.
OK.
So this molecule is
galactose, an important sugar
found in milk.
All right.
If I draw a glucose next
to it again, glucose--
so these two sugars differ
here, the stereochemistry there.
So they are, I guess,
isomers of each other.
There's a special name for
it I will get to in a second.
So that's how galactose
is related to glucose.
The other major aldose
hexose is this one.
This is D-mannose.
This differs from glucose here--
that carbon at that carbon.
By the way, by
convention, the way
that you number carbon
in sugars is you
start with the end that's
closest to the carbonyl, either
the aldehyde or the carbon
one up from the ketone,
so this would be carbon
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So galactose differs
from glucose at carbon 4.
Glucose differs from
mannose at carbon 2.
These isomers have names
in relation to each other.
And so two sugars that differ
by one part of stereochemistry--
so galactose to glucose
or glucose to mannose--
are called epimers.
And these can be or converted
by enzymes called epimerases.
We'll talk about how these
work later in the course.
And so glucose is an
epimer of galactose.
Glucose is an epimer of mannose.
Mannose is not an
epimer of galactose
because mannose and
galactose differ
at both carbon 2 and carbon 4--
their stereochemistry.
Why is that relevant?
Because if you're
going to interconvert
galactose and mannose,
you would have
to do it in two steps, two
different epimerase reactions
to interconvert
those two sugars.
All right.
Great.
So we've discussed now
all of the major hexoses
that nature uses.
We've discussed all the major
trioses that nature uses.
The other major
length of sugars that
ends up being important
in biochemistry
is the five-carbon
sugars, the pentoses.
And so I want to mention
a couple pentoses
and do so in a way that will
allow me to basically solidify
some of the nomenclature
that I've gone through.
And, of course, one of the
five carbon sugars-- ribose--
is really critical to
nucleic acid structure, which
is one of the reasons why
we're talking about this
at this point in the course.
OK.
So this is a pentose--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5-carbon
sugar, D-ribose.
All right.
It's a D sugar because
the stereocenter furthest
from the carbonyl
points to the right.
It's an aldose because
it has an aldehyde group.
I can act on this
with an isomerase.
I'm not going to draw out
the isomerase reaction again.
It's exactly what I drew before.
If I did this, now, I
turn this into a ketose.
Pentose because
it's five carbons.
Ketose because as a ketone.
D sugar because the
stereocenter furthest
from the carbonyl
points to the right.
This has a name of D-ribulose.
All right.
And it turns out that there
is an important epimer
of D-ribulose that's
found in nature.
The epimer changes the
stereochemistry at carbon 3--
carbon 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
That's carbon 3.
And so if this was acted on
by an epimerase that did that,
you get this sugar,
also a pentose,
also a ketose, a D sugar,
but an epimer of ribulose.
It's called D-xyulose.
It's an epimer because
xyulose ribulose
are epimers because they differ
by stereochemistry only at one
position.
I'll just say,
right off the bat,
you should not memorize names
of sugars and their structures.
These are things you
can look up in books.
The point of going
through all this
is just to expose you to
some of the nomenclature,
remind you about
stereochemistry.
I realize, these
are basic things.
Many of you have already
encountered this.
Some of you find this very easy.
Some people find these sort of
spatial things more difficult.
This is very well-reviewed,
though, in textbooks
or other places online if
you need to look it up.
But the key thing is just to
remember this nomenclature
because it'll make it easier for
us to talk about sugars later
in the course.
All right let's
take a short break,
so I can get some
board space back.
And then we'll build off some
of these concepts in a minute.
I've been drawing all of these
sugars as straight chains.
But you probably
know, from high school
or from looking at DNA or
RNA that the ribose there
is not a straight chain
but, instead, forms a ring.
And, in fact in solution,
particular aqueous
solution, sugars, particularly
five carbons and longer almost
always exist as rings.
And there is a very
clear reason for this.
And you probably remember,
from 512 Organic Chemistry
that alcohols will react
with aldehydes and ketones
in solution.
And so here, I have a model
of glucose and fructose
if you want to come
and play with them.
And so if you look at this,
and you just look at the model,
you see that this oxygen, right
here, this alcohol, in space,
is very close or can be moved to
be very close to this aldehyde
here on the end of the molecule.
Or the same thing
here with fructose.
Here's a alcohol very close
in space with this ketone.
All right.
So what happens
in this situation?
Well, if you have--
this is a review of
organic chemistry.
OK.
So here's any generic aldehyde.
Here's some alcohol.
OK.
So those things react.
You end up with this
so-called hemiacetol.
Or the same thing if I do it
with a ketone and an alcohol--
now you get this hemiketal.
OK.
Now given that you have
an alcohol reacting
with a carbonyl, an
aldehyde, or ketone
on the same molecule,
well, what happens
is you effectively
get a ring with oxygen
being one of the
components of the ring.
And so if we draw
this for glucose--
so this is D-glucose.
All right.
And so if the alcohol here
on carbon 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
interacts with the
aldehyde on carbon 1--
you can play with the
model and see that that is
the one that's close in space--
you now end up getting this.
This, where you get a ring
between carbons 1 and 5.
We can number the rest of them--
2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
All right.
Or if I turn this molecule
so that you can now draw it
in a slightly more
chemically proper way,
now, you basically have--
this is carbon 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So carbon 5, oxygen from
carbon 5 now bound to carbon 1
gives you this six-membered
ring structure.
The six-membered ring structure
is reminiscent of an organic
molecule called a--
looks like that-- called pyran.
And so this six-membered
ring in a sugar
is also referred
to as a pyranose.
All right.
So that's the first thing.
The second thing is
that this whole business
can be very tedious to draw.
In fact, it's very tedious
drawing sugars in general,
as I'm sure you would agree
with me if you're taking notes
during this lecture.
And so oftentimes, these
pyranoses, like glucose,
are drawn with shorthand.
And the shorthand is as follows,
where I basically represent
the OH groups as simply lines.
And so this is another
shorthand to draw
that pyranose form of glucose--
again, carbon 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Now the last thing is you
can see I didn't draw the OH
group there on carbon 1.
And that's because by
making this pyranose ring,
if you look at
carbon 1, I have now
generated a new stereocenter.
And so carbon 1 now has four
non-equivalent groups on it,
which means I could draw
the OH group, that carbon 1,
in two different ways.
And so this is carbon 1.
I could draw it such that
the OH group points down.
Or I could draw it such
that the OH group points up.
And those are two
different molecules.
And so there's a naming
convention for this too.
And so if the OH
group points down
using this way of drawing the
molecule, it's called alpha.
If the OH group points
up, it's called beta.
All right.
And so this alpha
versus beta ends up
being structurally different
because it puts, basically,
that OH group pointing in a very
different position in space.
So if I make a ring
here with glucose,
and the OH group is
pointing here versus there--
very different
position in space.
And this has
implications for how
you build bonds
for disaccharides
and polysaccharides that
make structural differences.
And we'll cover this a lot
when we get to metabolism.
But it should be very
clear now that glucose,
if you just take a solution of
glucose and put it in water,
it is not one thing.
There's actually multiple
different forms it can have.
It could be as I drew it up
here with the OH group pointing
down.
This would be alpha D-gluco--
because it's glucose--
pyranose, because it's
in the pyranose ring form.
I could have drawn it with
the OH group pointing up--
different molecule.
That would be Beta
D-glucopyranose.
Or it could just be the
open-chain D-glucose
that I was drawing earlier.
All right.
All of those are perfectly
legitimate ways for glucose
to exist in solution.
All right.
Now it turns out, that
in reality, about a third
of it in solution is this.
Two thirds is that.
And a trace amount is this.
OK.
And that has to
do with just what
is more favorable forms or not.
But which form it's in actually
matters for structural reasons,
as we'll see later
in the course.
Now the final complexity is
that this ring is not flat.
So if I actually take glucose
here and make a form of it--
so here's my glucose molecule.
There's no way for me to
make this completely flat,
say, like benzene.
And so there's really
two different pyranose
confirmations that
can be formed.
I'll try to draw them, but
they're harder to draw.
Here's a overhead that you
can look at if it's easier.
But basically, you can have it
form this so-called boat form
or this so-called chair form.
So there's the boat versus
the chair conformation.
Glucose, turns out, prefers
And there's an
interesting thing that
comes from this because if
you take beta D-glucopyranose,
it turns out of all
the hexoses that
exist in possible hexoses that
exist, the form of a hexose
aldose that best spreads
out all the hydroxyl groups
is beta D-glucopyranose, the
more common one in solution.
Why does this matter?
Well, because if this has this
reactive aldehyde bound up
in this stable ring
structure, it's
less likely to react with
other aldehydes in the cell.
And so this is likely why nature
chose D-glucose as the most
common storage sugar-- why
it's sugar in your blood--
because it's the most stable
hexose that's out there.
And it's not just
a random reason
that nature picked
this one, but actually
because of real
chemical stability
issues for why it's there.
All right.
Now I want to mention that
ketoses also can form rings.
And I'm going to use
this as an example
to show you that a ketose--
so here's fructose.
So this is D-fructose.
And so it turns out, this
can form two possible rings.
It can form a five-membered
ring or six-membered ring.
So how do I form a
five-membered ring?
So if I take the carbon
here from carbon 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, the hydroxyl from carbon
5, form a ring there.
Now, I get this molecule.
So there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
OK.
Or if I now turn this
so that I draw it
in the way you're probably
more used to seeing it,
I'm going to use
the shorthand here.
So this here would be
carbon 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6--
hydroxyl from carbon 5,
forming a bond to carbon 2.
That creates a new
stereocenter at carbon 2.
OH group is pointing up.
So this is a beta sugar--
OH group pointing up.
So this here, as I drew
it, would be beta D-fructo
and this is a furanose.
Why is that?
Because the organic
molecule that's
a five-membered ring with
an oxygen in it is a furan.
And so the five-membered ring
is referred to as a furanose--
beta D-fructofuranose.
If I'd drawn it with the
OH group pointing down,
it would be alpha
D-fructofuranose.
OK.
There's another
possible ring I can do.
And instead, I take the hydroxyl
from carbon 6 and do that--
form a ring.
Now I'm going to form
a six-membered ring.
We have carbon 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So if I now turn this--
so this, here, now I drew
the OH group pointing down.
So it's an alpha.
If I drew it up,
it would be beta.
So this is alpha
D-fructofuranose--
six-membered ring version of
fructose, five-membered ring
version of fructose.
So lots of non-equivalent
ways I can draw fructose.
And it turns out,
these actually matter.
And they matter for real things
that probably matter to you.
And so I brought with me here
two different sweeteners.
This is corn syrup.
This is honey.
Has anyone ever-- I'm sure
most of you have had honey.
Has anyone ever
tasted corn syrup?
Come on.
Someone's tasted corn syrup.
Is a sweet?
Which one's sweeter?
Honey, by far-- much,
much, much sweeter.
I used to have it so you guys
could come up and taste them.
But I couldn't
come up with a way
to do that in a sanitary way.
So I gave up on it.
But nonetheless-- much
sweeter than that.
It turns out, these
are not pure fructose.
They're a combination of sugars.
But their composition
is actually,
from a chemical
standpoint, similar amounts
of fructose in each one.
And it turns out that honey
is beta D-fructopyranose.
Whereas corn syrup is
beta D-fructofuranose.
All right.
So same sugar, different
structure-- one's a furanose,
one's a pyranose--
tastes very differently to
you, one being much more sweet,
one being much less sweet.
OK.
Now, of course, I also want to
talk about ribose because it's
the thing that
you guys are going
to talk about the most next
because it's in nucleic acids.
And so just as a
reminder, here's ribose.
It's a aldose and a pentose.
So this is D-ribose.
Ribose, as from high school,
forms five-membered rings.
That's because it links
alcohol on carbon 4
to the aldehyde on carbon 1.
And that gives you
this ring structure.
Now number of carbons--
1, 2, 3, 4--
alcohol on carbon
4, forming a ring
to the aldehyde on carbon 1.
This is carbon 5.
And the way I drew it,
OH group pointing up--
so this is beta D-ribofuranose
would be the proper way
to have it.
And so when you guys
talk about this in DNA,
well, the base is going
to be linked to carbon 1.
It's going to replace
that hydroxyl group--
the beta form of the hydroxyl
group with the nitrogen.
And you're going to talk
about bonds being from the 5
prime or the 3 prime end.
Those are those hydroxyl groups.
That's where 5 prime
and 3 prime comes
from because those are the 5
and the 3 position on ribose.
Great.
Perfect.
All right.
So we will return to
carbohydrates in great detail.
We'll discuss how we combine
different carbohydrates,
different monosaccharides
to make disaccharides
and polysaccharides, how these
different structural properties
end up mattering for
things like energy storage
as well as to produce various
structural molecules that
can be important for
different cells in organisms.
But for the remaining
part of the class today,
I really want to shift
topics to now discuss
a completely different
class of biomolecules.
And that's lipids.
So as I said earlier, the
reason we're going to do this
is because coming up for
Professor Yaffe's lectures,
lipids end up being
really important molecules
for various aspects
of cell signaling.
They're also very important
for energy transduction,
which is why I'm talking
about them as well.
We will spend a lot
of time later talking
about lipids in great detail.
But really, what I
want to focus on today
is how lipids are used
to create membranes.
That is, barriers that really
separate the outside world
from the inside of cells,
things that make compartments
within cells, and
these things also
end up being surfaces where
you can have key things happen.
So you reduce spatial
complexity if you
go to a 2D surface
versus a 3D surface,
which is part of why they're
so important in signal
transduction.
But to talk about these,
I have to introduce, first
of all, what is a lipid?
So lipids are a
class of molecules.
You think of them as fats.
That's how they fit in the
nutritional standpoint of what
we'll all talk about.
But first, I want to
give a general definition
of what a lipid is.
Now there's lots of
different classes of lipids.
And we'll cover these
later in the course.
But in general, at
the highest level,
almost all lipids
consist of two pieces--
consist of something
called a fatty acid that's
esterified to an alcohol.
So what is a fatty acid?
Well, a fatty acid is
really any molecule that
has a carboxylic acid group.
So there's a carboxylic acid.
And then hooked up to
that carboxylic acid
is a whole bunch of saturated
hydrocarbons-- alkyl chains.
Oftentimes, fatty acid would be
drawn like this because of all
the different saturated chains.
So acid group on one
end, really greasy alkyl
chain on the other.
And it turns out that this can
be esterified to an alcohol.
So here's just a
generic alcohol.
And as you certainly remember
from organic chemistry,
I can use an alcohol and
an acid to form an ester.
And so then that would be--
so now, I have, basically,
this ester bond.
And this is esterification
between some lipid species
and a fatty acid, in
general, is the general thing
that leads to a class of
molecules known as lipids.
Now why this is particularly
useful for biology
is that this long, greasy alkyl
chain is not water soluble.
So if you take oil
from your cabinet--
canola oil, or olive
oil, or whatever, and you
pour it in water, what happens?
It doesn't mix together.
You get these globs of
oil floating in the water.
And so if you want to
form a barrier between two
aqueous compartments, a
way to do this is to have,
basically, a hydrophobic layer--
a membrane-- basically separate
the two aqueous compartments,
the inside and the
outside of the cell.
Now if I take a lipid, and
the lipid, I form this ester,
and it doesn't have a charged
group anywhere on the molecule,
this is sometimes referred
to as a neutral lipid.
So what do I mean
by neutral lipid?
It's basically taking this,
which is intrinsically
a fatty acid, is intrinsically
a polar molecule.
It has this carboxylic
acid on the end of it.
But if I form an ester
linkage to an alcohol,
and the alcohol has
no charge on it,
now, it's just this
really greasy molecule.
And it turns out, that's exactly
what is in your olive oil
or in your canola
oil in your cabinet.
It's basically a
bunch of fatty acids--
long alkyl chains esterified
to non-charged alcohols,
which makes this neutral lipid,
this greasy molecule, which
is great for energy storage
in plants, something
we'll talk about.
But if you want to mix
it together with water,
it doesn't do very well.
So if you go to
make salad dressing,
and you pour your oil
in with your vinegar,
the aqueous thing, you
get a bunch of droplets.
You don't get a solution.
And if you think
about it, that's
not very good at generating
an interface between two
compartments.
You just get a
bunch of droplets.
You actually don't
get an interface
between two compartments.
So if you want to
make an interface,
you have to do
something different.
You need to have a charge group,
like on this fatty acid, that's
going to be happy sticking
towards the aqueous side
and then a hydrophobic portion
that's going to be happy
sticking to form a barrier.
Effectively, that's
what soap is.
So if you want to wash your
hands and use canola oil,
it doesn't work
very well, right?
But what happens if you
have a bunch of greasy stuff
in the water, and you take a
drop of dawn dish detergent
and drop it in the water?
You get this immediate
barrier that forms
across the top as you get
this film where you basically
align up all these
charged hydrophilic parts
to the aqueous pieces and
all of the greasy parts
to the hydrophobic side.
So you end up having this
nice charged molecule
with this long hydrophobic part.
So you have a hydrophilic
end and a hydrophobic end.
And that ends up being
very useful as a way
to form an aqueous
hydrophobic interface.
And this is exactly
how soap works,
as I'm sure you've
learned in other classes.
As an aside, you know
how you make soap?
You basically boil the
neutral lipids in lye.
So boiling it in
base, if you remember
from organic chemistry, will
break the ester linkage.
And now, you have
these molecules.
And that's how you make soap.
All right.
Now the way biology does
this is they actually
assemble lipids that effectively
have that same property, where,
basically, they have a head
group from the alcohol that's
charged with a hydrophobic
group contributed
from these fatty acids.
And this is what allows things
to assemble into membranes.
And so membranes are largely
made up of-- and certainly,
for the purposes of
the upcoming lectures--
so-called phospholipids.
So what is a phospholipid?
Well, on a phospholipid, the
alcohol part of the lipid
is derived from a
molecule called glycerol.
So glycerol looks like this.
OK.
So this is glycerol.
All right.
3-carbon molecule--
three alcohols--
actually, very similar.
If you look back in your
notes to dihydroxyacetone,
the difference between
glycerol and dihydroxyacetone
is carbon 2 was an alcohol
here before it was a ketone.
Turns out, that's where glycerol
comes from-- dihydroxyacetone
getting turned into glycerol.
And basically,
what a phospholipid
is that you esterify
a fatty acid
to two of the alcohols
and another phosphate
and charged alcohol to
the other hydroxyl group.
So what do I mean by that?
So like this-- so here's
ester linkage number one.
I'll draw it this
way just for ease.
This is the carbon 2.
Here's ester linkage number two.
So that's a fatty acid
esterified to 2 and 3.
And then you now make
an ester to a phosphate.
So there's a
phosphate at carbon 1.
And then you make another ester
linkage to another alcohol
where R equals alcohol.
And that alcohol also
turns out to be charged.
And so the most common
phospholipid membrane lipid
is a molecule called
phosphatidylcholine,
which is that structure with
the R group being this alcohol.
And so this is choline.
OK and so phosphatidylcholine
is basically that structure.
OK.
So this is phosphatidylcholine
drawn out in all of its glory.
So you have this
hydrophilic end.
Here, you have a
hydrophobic end.
That's good.
This can point towards
the aqueous side.
the greasy side
and make a nice interface.
And so another common word
for phosphatidylcholine--
an old word for it--
is a molecule called lecithin.
Anyone read the labels on
the side of your food ever?
In fact, there's
an old commercial
that makes fun of this.
Soy lecithin?
What's that?
I don't want that
in my ice cream.
Well, what is lecithin?
It's phosphatidylcholine.
It's basically,
why is this done?
Well, it's commonly
added to ice cream
because what is ice cream?
And it's an emulsion
between fat,
the cream, and sugar, which
is pretty aqueous solubles,
you might guess, from looking
at what we drew earlier today.
And so by putting
phosphatidylcholine
in your ice cream, you basically
stabilize this emulsion
between the aqueous
and the fat face.
So this is why it's
added to lots of food.
And in fact, it says, soy
lecithin, an emulsifier.
That's why it's added.
You can do this yourself.
This is a common trick
that many cooks know.
So if you make salad dressing,
you put a little mayonnaise
in your salad dressing.
Why do you do that?
Well, mayonnaise has eggs in it.
Eggs have a lot of
phosphatidylcholine.
That mayonnaise that you
add into your salad dressing
basically stabilizes
that emulsion
between the oil in the vinegar
and helps it be more stable
and distribute better
across your lettuce.
I think my favorite
example of this
is, who's made
chocolate chip cookies?
Everyone's done this, right?
OK.
So how do you make
chocolate chip cookies?
So you take butter and sugar,
all right, fat, and something
that's very non--
very polar, aqueous
soluble sugar.
And you try to
mix them together.
You have to cream it, right?
And that takes forever.
It's a pain in the butt.
It doesn't come
together very well.
And so you get lazy, and
you put the egg in there.
And then it all comes together
really, really easily.
So why is that?
The egg is the emulsifier that
actually brings it together.
Whereas trying to get
the butter and sugar
to make your cookies
nice and fluffy
is a lot harder
because you're really
trying to get these two
things to come together.
And it's basically
this exact chemistry
that's taking place when you're
doing that act of cooking.
All right.
Now phosphatidylcholine is
not the only phospholipid
found in membranes.
But I'll just quickly mention
what a couple of the other ones
are.
So it turns out you have two
other major phospholipids
by abundance and then
another phospholipid that's
really important for signaling.
So I'll list them here first.
So there's phosphatidylserine,
phosphatidylethanolamine
These, it turns out,
phosphatidylcholine,
phosphatidylserine,
phosphatidylethanolamine is
what makes up the majority
of the phospholipids in cell
membranes.
And then there is a much
more minor phospholipid
that's important for signaling,
which is phosphatidylinositol.
So what are these?
So serine, ethanolamine,
and inositol
are just, like choline,
different alcohols
that can be esterified to
the phosphate in exactly
the same way I did for
phosphatidylcholine.
And so what's
phosphatidylserine?
So if you remember, this is--
so this here is the
amino acid serine.
I'm sure you remember that.
If we esterify that
alcohol to the phosphate,
there's phosphatidylserine.
What's ethanolamine look like?
So ethanolamine is this alcohol.
So that's ethanolamine.
Esterify the alcohol
to phosphate.
Esterify that
phosphate to glycerol--
phosphatidylethanolamine.
And the last one is inositol.
So what is inositol?
Well, inositol is a
six-membered hydrocarbon rain
where all of the carbons
have an alcohol on them.
And so if I esterify one of
these alcohols on inositol,
versus a--
if I esterify one
of those alcohols
to a phosphate to make
phosphatidylinositol,
turns out that that ends up
being a really useful lipid
to make for signaling.
And you'll hear a lot about
this in a couple of contexts,
I believe, from Professor
Yaffe later in the course.
All right.
So this having these
general membrane structure
or this general
phospholipid structure,
where you have this hydrophobic
part of the molecule
and the hydrophilic
is really what allows these
lipids to come together
to form these membrane bilayers
that are often drawn like this.
And so when I'm
drawing it like this,
basically, what
those two wavy lines
represent-- those are the
hydrophobic fatty acid parts,
and this is the hydrophilic
so-called head group.
That's the charged alcohol
stuck on to the end of the--
to the phosphate
on the glycerol.
And these, of
course, assemble such
that all of the
hydrophilic head groups
face an aqueous
compartment on either side.
OK.
And then you have this
nice hydrophobic portion
that is a membrane.
And that is what
can create a barrier
between two different
compartments in cells.
Now just to put
this into context
for the protein structure
stuff that you learned about--
so when you learn about
all the different ways
you have protein
structure, of course,
you have amino acids
that are hydrophilic,
amino acids that
are hydrophobic.
If you have a protein
that's floating in solution,
it has all the hydrophilic
parts on the outside
and the hydrophobic
parts in the middle.
But you can imagine
that you can also
have proteins that
assemble to sit such
that they span the membrane-- so
hydrophobic parts that interact
with the hydrophobic
part, the inner part
of the membrane-- hydrophilic
parts on either side.
These can form channels.
These can form all kinds of ways
to move stuff across membranes.
Or you might think that you
might have a protein that
does something like that--
hydrophobic part on one end,
hydrophilic part on the other,
and really floats on the
surface of a membrane.
And you will see that the
way cell signaling works
is that you basically have
lots of protein complexes
that will assemble
that membranes--
two dimensional space.
Those membranes, as well as
some of the membrane lipids,
can then act as messengers
that allow cells to carry out
various signals.
And I will leave that to
Professor Yaffe to talk about.
All right.
So I will also come back
and discuss membranes
in a very different context
in the context of metabolism
during the second
half of the course
because it turns out, a
lot of energy transduction
and the way cells
really store energy also
ends up being really important
with respect to membranes.
All right.
You guys are lucky.
You get out a little
bit early today.
This is the first
time that we've
done the lectures this way,
so I don't have my timing
quite right.
But I will see you guys
again for metabolism
after spring break.